and applied linear algebra matrix math
quality addition and subtraction are
some of the simplest concepts that we're
going to go over today let's get started
to test for equality you compare element
by element within your matrix to say
that maybe this is a 2 by 1 matrix with
2 rows 2 by 1 2 rows and 1 column and
then we want to test for equality now
the most obvious thing is if they just
have some number or formula and then and
the other side is the same those are
equal because each element matches but
where it becomes interesting with
equality is you can have a formula or a
function on one side and the result on
the other and then it essentially turns
into an algebra equation something like
well maybe you'll have 7x here and let's
change these two maybe you have 7x plus
1 as this first element here and row 1
column 1 and over here we have 15 and
let's put another random thing down here
like 9 plus 2y and over here maybe we'd
have a another 15 so from this we can
since it tells us they're equal we know
that this element here is the same as
this element here which would allow us
to solve for x
so it would turn into this and of course
X here would be 2 because 7 times 2 is
14 plus another one is 15 and likewise
for this bottom one we could do the same
thing we know that they're equal we'll
get set it up like so and in this case
what would this Y be see if you can
figure that one out on your own it's 3 9
plus 6 equals 15
so Y would be 3 so that's how a quality
works
it's just element by element and now
let's talk about addition and
subtraction to add or subtract matrices
they need to be the exact same size
let's say these are each 2 by 2
I'll just put two by two down here
[Music]
random numbers that's an 8 1 and 9 and a
10 and this would equal a running out of
room here a matrix of the same size
where each element is just added
together or for this first one it is 7
plus 8 which is of course 15 and the
next one is 2 plus 1 which was of course
3 and then 6 plus 9 which is of course
15 and then 1 plus 10 and that would be
those two matrices added together
subtraction works pretty much the same
way element by element so I think you
can figure that out on your own it is
important that they are the same size
or you just can't do the operation and
it is an illegal try so one last thing
here is these to follow the standard
rules of addition and and subtraction
where they are commutative and
associative and basically what that
means is the order of them doesn't
matter so you could put this matrix
first and this one second and they would
equal the same thing or if you added a
third matrix in here that was 2x2 to add
to it you would just keep adding up the
results and the order of course doesn't
matter okay that's gonna do it for this
episode please leave a like and check
the links below to help support this
channel if you'd like to see more videos
higher quality videos etc etc I'm a
young growing channel a young growing
boy in the youtube world so I could use
any support that I could get have a good
day and keep on learning guys